علي وزاره الخارجيه الايرانيه قالت اليوم
ايضا ان طهران سترفض التعاون مع لجنه
تقصير حقائق التي شكلتها الامم المتحده
مؤخرا للتحقيق في الاجراءات التي اتخذتها
البلاد التصدي للاحتجاجات المناهضه
للحكومه
من قبل السلطات الايرانيه فالسلطات
الايرانيه همم ليس فقط لمنظمه حقوق
الانسان وانما لكافه المنظمات الدوليه
النشي- الناشطه في مجلس الامن تعتبر ان
هذه المنظمات
سياسيه في ايدي الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه
والدول الاوروبيه تحركها كيفما تشاء
لتحقيق مكاسب سياسيه تفرض من خلالها
الضغوط على طهران في المفاوضات النوويه
التي تقوده طيران مع اربعه زائد واحد ولا
اجباري طهران على تقديم المزيد من
التنازلات التي لم توافق على تقديمها حتى
همم نعم بالنسبه اشارتهم في التقرير
اعتقال ابن اخت المرشد الاعلى
لانها قبل ان تكون اخت المرشد على ابنها
الشيخ علي اتخانى المعروف للشيخ علي
طهراني وهو رجل دين الشيعي كان مناهضا همم
لحكومه الشاه الايراني السابق
ولكن بعد انتصار الثوره الاسلاميه اصبح من
المعارضين ايضا لسياسه الامام الخميني
قائد الثوره الاسلاميه الايرانيه هجر او
حتى هرب الى العراق وخاض نشاطه السياسي من
داخل الاراضي العراقيه في فتره من الفترات
كان يدعم ايضا منظمه مجاهده خالقه
المعارضه والتي خاضت كفاحا مسلحا ضد
السلطات الايرانيه في فتره من الفترات عاد
الى طرفان توفي السنه الماضيه ابنته ايضا
هي ناشطه حقوقيه همم سياسيه اجتماعيه همم
معروفه هنا في ايران تم اعتقالها في عده
مناسبات اخر مره كانت عام الماضي وتم
الافراج عنها قبل اربعه شهور تقريبا من
الان اعتقالها لم يكن مفاجاه لكن حقيقه في
هذا التوقيت همم يبدو ان السلطات
الايرانيه من خلال تشديد القبضه الامنيه
من السيطره على الشارع خروج المظاهرات
الكبيره كما في همم السابقه قررت التصدي
الى
المظاهرات او مظاهر الاعتراض التي تنتشر
عبر مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي اعتقال ابنه
الاخت المرشد لاعلى تحمل رسائل كثيرا لكل
من ينشط عبر وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي ايضا
كان هناك اعتقال للاعب كره قدم مشهور
لاعبي كره القدم الدولي مشهور فوليا
غافوري تم الافراج عنه مؤخرا بكفاله ايضا
كان هناك اعتقال لممثلات
ايرانيات تم الافراج عنهم كفاله ايضا كتاب
هنا هي رساله واضحه من السلطات الايرانيه
تريد ان تقول انها تريد السيطر ايضا على
همم العالم الافتراضي كما سيطره على
الشارع في الحقيقه في الايام الاخيره
بالفعل تجديد القبضه الامنيه شكرا لك علي
على كل هذه التفاصيل كلها مباشره